lombardo speaking to eight news now this
morning giving his take on the riot in
our nation's capital a week ago
and he also touched on the local
security measures he tells us because of
the large number of demonstrations and
protests over the last
six to nine months the department is
prepared for these types of situations
we've had plenty of practice with the
people out protesting doing their first
amendment rights and
everything else that goes along with it
but in this case
there was a warning obviously the
president said what he said
um and individuals weren't prepared
and that's my opinion i believe law
enforcement was ill prepared
to deal with the situation that took
place and so now we have a warning
we we're aware that there may be
interesting
occurring here on the 20th and we're
putting people in place and plans in
place to
to address it accordingly the sheriff
says following last week's events troops
were deployed here to our local
courthouse federal courthouse
and state capitol he also tells us metro
is investigating if any of its police
officers took part in the deadly riot if
they did they could face losing their
job